[Music]  Taylor Swift took a small tumble during  Sunday's reputation world tour stop in  New Jersey but as expected she handled  it like a pro getting right back up and  laughing it off the fall happen during  Taylor's performance of call it what's  wrong and while it's unclear what caused  the trip the stage could have been wet  from Saturday's show when she performed  her entire sets in the pouring rain at  the same venue I don't understand how  you cannot fangirl about that earlier  Sunday Taylor wished her BFF Selena  Gomez a happy 26th birthday on Instagram  baking a cake that said Gomez or go home  and writing Willy let distance stop me  from celebrating my best friend's bday I  mean I could but why would I want to  what I loved about that that friendship  is it's so solid and and with Taylor I  feel like they can tell each other  anything and like it will be an honest  like in your best interest kind of  relationship yeah it's not about  anything else